- I like that the eyelashes
matches my chest hair.
(upbeat music)
Today, I'm trying on some fake eyelashes.
- I never thought I'd see the day.
- Do girls wear eyelash extensions?
Is that common?
- I think they do it all the time
and I just don't notice.
- I'm super excited.
- I feel like it's going to be glamorous.
- You know, I'll do what I can.
- So I have no clue what I'm doing.
- Oh (bleeped), I think
I just (bleeped) it up.
- Anything where you have to
put like glue on your face
should just be an immediate no.
Like, you don't, no.
- Oh yeah, I'm going to kill it.
- It might work, I'll be fine.
- [Voiceover] This is
not very easy to apply
a thin line of adhesive.
- Eww, this looks like semen.
- So here we go.
- Ugh.
- I feel like girls should
be like bomb diffusers
cause they're so good at
like these little tasks.
- I can't get it.
- Well, it's a little high.
It's very high.
- Eww.
- I can see the gap
between the fake lashes
and my real lashes.
- It's just so hard.
How does anyone ever wear these?
My eyes are like really glued
shut right now (laughs).
- Thank God this stuff dries clear.
- Oh, it's starting to
feel like hard on this eye.
- It really does accentuate your eyes,
like I have beautiful
eyes, I didn't even know.
I feel like a princess, I do.
- God, it feels like I
have like a piece of hair
in my eye forever.
- This is what you're getting today.
- Ahhh.
- I feel cool.
I feel like Lady Gaga.
- I look good bitch, check me out, bam.
- Wow, that's a pain in the ass.
I'm sorry for any woman or man
who has ever done this.
- It's very feminine.
I wonder why my mind says
it's feminine looking.
- I think it's cool.
God, I wish guys can accessorize
and it just not be an issue.
- I just don't like it.
It feels weird.
- I now have a new found appreciation
for the skill it takes to get it right on
where it should be.
- I feel like with practice
I could probably be
like the best.
- God bless you if you do this everyday,
like Jesus Lord, God bless you.
- I can't see anything.
My eyes are like glued shut right now.
(upbeat music)